Okay let's work on the solution for our ROB timing quiz.
The final question was, when does the ADD here, the last instruction commit?
To do that we have to figure out, what happens with the last two instructions.
So can we issue the subtract in cycle 5? Yes we can.
Only one of the, add subtract reservation stations is used at that time.
In cycle 5 it actually will be freed so
from cycle 6 we actually have all the reservations in add subtract available,
but for sure one is available in cycle 5. And then the third one,
we can use it in cycle 6. In fact, by that time, this one is also available, so
we, we can just issue these instructions. The subtract here, uses R2 and
R5. R5 is not produced by any of the previous instructions but R2 is.
So, we actually have to wait until cycle 7 before we can. Proceed to execution.
Now, because in cycle 7, other instructions are also beginning execution,
we have to figure out can we actually run this subtract now or
do we have to wait for the next cycle. So we want to run it in cycle 7,
but remember, this is a multiplication. This is a subtract, so they're using
different execution units and they can begin in the same cycle. If another, for
example add or subtract was beginning at seven, then we would actually have to
wait until eight. But because these are different units we can begin at seven,
And we're going to try to broadcast our result at eight.
Nobody else is trying to broadcast at eight, so we will succeed at that.
And finally, for the add here, it's waiting for
R4 and R3. R4 is produced by this subtract. R3 is produced here. So
we need to wait for cycles five and eight and then begin in cycle nine. We will
try to broadcast in cycle ten. And now the question is when do they commit?
. Remember that we can commit up to two instructions per cycle. So what's
going to happen. Is in cycle 10. We're going to also try to commit to subtract.
We only committing this multiplication so far. We can commit two instructions.
We'll try to commit to the next instruction. So
in cycle 10 we will actually commit this. And now interestingly enough,
this add is done just in time to write to commit to cycle 11.
So it's going to commit to cycle 11. So, the final answer for
the final part of the quiz is that the commit is happening in cycle 11, here.